this might be the worst exploit in CS2
so far oh no not again for a few tense
hours a workshop map exploit apparently
allowed the owner to include a script
that would in theory let them control
items in your inventory including
opening cases deleting items trading up
and worst of all applying or scraping
stickers are you kidding me so someone
could literally hack you through a
Workshop app considering how much some
people's inventories cost this was
scary thankfully the valve devs fixed
the issue quite quickly but at the cost
of disabling all custom elements and
scripts in Workshop Maps it's all good
guys at least people can't change their
usernames to literal porn wait hey yo
what the